[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est toujours un regard
nouveau et puis une sensibilité
peut-être un peu différente puisque la
palette de change un peu les temps sont
plus chauds beaucoup plus chaud puisque
je suis arrivé à passer au rouge ce qui
était pas dans ma palette habituel mais
tout en gardant bien sûr le bleu qui est
toujours omniprésent dans la peinture
quand le petit le travail se fait
plaisir ça c'est sûr d'abord mais il est
comme je dis toujours illégal altruiste
il va à la rencontre de son public
parce que si on le perd on ne produit on
fait des pièces de théâtre on fait de la
musique on paie que pour échanger pour
montrer ce conflit c'est inadmissible de
penser qu'on pourrait faire une toile et
puis confirme dans un placard
de toute façon la toile n'existe pas une
fois qu'elle est pas vu ce qui met en
évidence la production de l'entée c'est
le regard du spectateur
programmé une rencontre avec le public
le 2 le 2 février
il s'éteint samedi donc à partir de 10
heures à 10 heures
je vais faire de nouvelles invitations
pour rencontrer le public n'a pas pu
venir le jour du vernissage et échanger
avec eux sous forme de discussion à
bâtons rompus
non
[Musique]